lundi 9 janvier 2010 est couché à 5
heures du matin lever à 7h je sens que
la journée va être compliqué du coup
j'ai commencé ma journée par un petit
bol aujourd'hui on va parler politique
alors pas de politique partisane parce
que fondamentalement je suis pas du tout
partisan pourrait se poser une question
qui va toucher tout le monde
il ya les primaires socialistes qui
arrive juste avant l'élection
présidentielle la question c'est doit-on
s'intéresser aux primaires socialistes
qu'on soit socialiste où l'on reçoit
droite ou non
quel que soit votre parti est ce qu'on
doit s'y intéresser oui ou non en règle
générale on se pose pas c'est la
question de ces primaires et pourtant
elle a un vrai sens quel que soit le
parti
et quelle que soit son opinion politique
parce que quoi qu'on en pense ce qui
reste est hyper primordial c'est de bien
connaître les tendances qui lie à ossun
de la partie si c'est en partie de coeur
qui fait sa primaire tu vas tu
intéresser davantage
tu vas probablement écouter ce qu'ont
les candidats dire pour faire ton choix
à la fin et du coup tu as toute
légitimité à aller voter
mais a contrario cité d'un autre parti
et que tu es dunes autres mouvances
en règle générale les gens ne
s'intéressent pas ou s'intéressent
beaucoup trop peu ils ne vont pas voter
à mon avis ils ont tort il ya la
personne qui est convaincue par le parti
et qui valait choisir son candidat
il ya la personne d'un autre parti qui
va aller voter uniquement pour aller
choisir un candidat qui a relativement
peu de chance face à son candidat lui et
vous avez un troisième type de personne
qui va s'intéresser à cette primaire pas
forcément quelqu'un qui va aller voter
mais qui malgré tout a tout intérêt à
s'y intéresser et je pense que c'est ce
qu'il faut faire sur un premier tour
d'une primaire
tu vas avoir différents candidats et
l'ensemble des candidats même s'ils sont
dans la même famille politique
ils vont pas forcément avoir les mêmes
avis les mêmes opinions et la même
vision pour la politique nationale en
réalité au sein d'un parti a toujours
différents courants différents courants
qu'ont connues souvent traversé
différentes personnalités
et c'est justement là tout l'intérêt de
s'intéresser à ces primaires une fois
que le candidat est sorti des urnes il
va aller se présenter lui à l'élection
présidentielle imaginons qu'il soit élu
qu'il devienne le nouveau président de
la république
[Musique]
une fois qu'il sera élu président de la
république
qu'est-ce qu'il va devoir faire il va
devoir nommer un premier ministre et le
premier ministre va former un
gouvernement
le gouvernement doit être formé avec des
ministres issus de sa majorité
rares sont les premiers ministres et les
présidents qui vont ouvrir leurs
gouvernements aux compétences de
l'opposition c'est déjà arrivé par le
passé mais c'est quand même relativement
rares ça relève souvent de tactique
politicienne
donc les politiciens qui seront au sein
du gouvernement devront d'une part
suivre la politique menée par le chef de
l'état mais également par le premier
ministre mais ils ont forcément leur mot
à dire lorsque vous êtes à la tête d'un
ministère vous êtes là pour appliquer
mais vous êtes là aussi pour ordonner si
vous qui décidez et c'est vous quelque
part qui dictaient aussi vos règles il
ya des ministères clés les affaires
étrangères l'intérieur j'en passe et des
meilleurs si les personnes qui sont
nommés à ses ministères là vous ne les
connaissez pas vous ne savez pas quelle
est leur vision quelles sont leurs idées
vous risquez d'avoir des surprises c'est
en ça que c'est passionnant et qu'il
faut s'intéresser à ces primaires pas
forcément pour aller voter si c'est pas
votre mouvance politique mais ne serait
ce que pour savoir qui sont les gens
qu'est ce qu'ils proposent qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent parce que les choses qui
seront proposées la même cette personne
là n'est pas le candidat et même si elle
n'est pas élue
vous avez de fortes chances de la
retrouver plus tard et de retrouver
malgré tout une partie de ses idées sur
le papier parce que au final et j'arrête
après avec ces considérations la
politique c'est quoi c'est redonner au
peuple ce qui lui revient de plein droit
sa liberté décidé de choisir ses
représentants et d'asseoir sa
souveraineté donc si on ne s'intéresse
pas on a toutes les chances d'être déçus
bien que même en s'intéressant on a tout
les genres des déçus
[Musique]